well it is a little bit quiet here hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to alphabet lame now believe it
or not and I know it's hard to believe
judging by Cookie Monster leering at you
with that brilliant smile of his but I
believe that this is a Sesame Street
horror game just a demo mind you and it
may look like ass I don't know the whole
concept of having ooh doesn't look like
as much asses I thought it might but the
whole concept of having the characters
of Sesame Street chasing and all right
then I'll do that I was in the middle of
talking about this game and how it was
weird that Sesame Street might be coming
to kill me maybe this game looks a bit
more like acid I thought it did but I
won't let that dissuade me I've gotta
find the keys wherever they may be are
they in the fridge giorgia Oh what the
hell oh wait open
oh man the walk is so slow Cookie
Monster have you come to claim me oh no
I don't know
and cookies oh no II got a munch on me
well then that's a little bizarre so I
believe I have a light shining from my
head
excuse me
is that that's all the response I can
muster to this hard anymore are you
washing her okay
I'm gonna ignore the fact I'm gonna
ignore the fact that this looks like a
play-doh character eating cookies I need
did I die
what oh okay all right then I guess I
got I guess I I guess what I'm supposed
to do is not go near the giant Cookie
Monster
Sal what if let's get out all this well
I wonder what's happening over here huh
oh the door has been blasted open I did
not know this fat you keep meeting
friends I'm just gonna go over here all
right then what am I gonna do in here
[ __ ] myself or try not to [ __ ] my wall
found my keys huh well that's all I
meant to do this whole time
better just you know skedaddle on out of
here I don't want to run don't uh
startle you have fun there you're having
a good time
cookies are gone where the hell did I go
I'm [ __ ] out of here get out of my
way oh man
Oh big bird doesn't come stomping down
the hallway next Oh help loading this
may take a while why today's depend
anniversary of the death of the Alabama
cutter
the infamous serial killer he is shot
down at the alphabet Lane Studio it
ultimately of the day the cutter aired
episode 17 where the cutter down the
body
puppeteering the power kids garden sure
you know what why not I'm gonna suspend
my disbelief here about there being a
crazed murderer in alphabet studios and
just assume that this is all gonna go
according to plan and everyone is just
okay with this and I'm okay with there
being ravenous Cookie Monster in my own
kitchen oh this is why are they chained
up
what are they chained up this doesn't
seem very kid to show friendly oh good
an axe I'll take that oh yeah can I
swing swung my axe can I swing it he
swung okay I'll just follow the green
lights then don't worry about me oh I
did good why can't I can't see [ __ ] I
did good I think okay here we go
okay Wow alright then didn't expect that
tax to be happening I can't believe I
was scared by that way what kind of
decrepit [ __ ] kids showed production
studio is this
[ __ ] was that let's take your time on
that one don't worry about the speed up
your this year in the burning coming for
me I did it mierda fuel only a boom dude
making fun of him he's gonna come after
me maybe not maybe so no he's gonna go
really late in case the flood the door
will not open till the flood to stopped
did I do it I guess I did it okay
I'm by Swedish chef's I've made five yo
well it is a little bit quiet take that
one back don't know why that happened
but uh okay Swedish Chef heard when I
was talking [ __ ] and he came back to
haunt me
at this point is my fault at this point
is my fault at this point is very much
my fault yeah a hundred percent my fault
so don't go near the vents is what I'm
learning from all this ooh I see a
wrench I don't know what that is but I'm
not turning around
that's for damn babe there's a Swedish
Chef just sliding across the floor on
his own meatball fat Jesus Christ okay
if a van just leaking hot steam by the
entrance or exit please use an available
tool to open the vent far away from the
exit to the same room generator
generators I don't get what that means
but I need to do some stuff with the
tool and I am the world's biggest tool
so here we go I'll start down there oh
is that a - dad I need I think that is
okay so I got a tool oh well that's
blasting a whole lot of ass load of
steam so I got a do a vent somewhere
away from it well here a Swedish Chef
whispering here
I'm gonna assume that's a bad vent but
hey it was bad been [ __ ] whoa okay
then I guess I did it already then I
didn't know what I did but I did it
[ __ ] or I need to activate the regulator
to be by yeah but that's Swedish bastard
oh there we go
I think that did it okay so I should be
good now I should just be able to go
down this way yep okay and then I can go
through the door and then all is good in
the world right yes maybe I don't know
actually got the sweats from some of
those it was my own fault oh it's good
do that you're gonna throw the Swedish
chef at me a few times and I was gonna
give me a big bird come on I'm begging
for big bird give me the biggest bird
you can find I want it all over me come
on Oh fine okay so that's the end of
alphabet lane I couldn't resist
make it a video about this I literally
couldn't resist the concept was so funny
to me and in all honesty and sometimes
just jump scares are fun and jump scares
in the way that it's Sesame Street care
just coming up to you and especially the
Swedish Chef coming after you that's is
hilarious so thank you everybody so much
for watching I hope you guys enjoyed
this one too the developer don't take
anything I said offensively I like this
I honestly had a great time with this
it's a silly concept but hey sometimes
silly concepts need to be explored and
to see what they can do so let me know
what you thought of the game down in the
comments below and let the developer
know what you thought of their game over
on their game page I'll put a look at
the description thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]